THERE IS SOME SUNDAY HOCKEY HAS
A SAY.THE
DEFLECTION OUT FRONT.
CAROLINA OFF TO A ON THE DEFENS.
IT GOES TO THE RIGHT SIDE OF
FREDERIK ANDERSEN.
THE CANES ARE ABLE TO CLEAR.
STAAL CENSUS INTO THE ANAHEIM
ZONE.
AND, GIBSON, WHWH.
THEY WILL SCORE!
JORDAN STAAL, NIEDERREITER'S
STAAL.
LOOK AT THAT  JOSH MAHURA FIRES
INSIDE THE BLUE LINE.
THAT IS DEEP.IT.
JARVIS GETS TO IT.
IT IS INTERRUPTED FROM JARVIS.
MARTINOOK.
THE CANES, WITH THE
SVECHNIKOV  SEALED THE OUTLET.
SHOT FROM ZEGRAS.
ANAHEIM SCORES.
I THOUGHT PART,
PARTNER.
WITHIN THE BLUE PAINT, THE
GOALTENDER HAS TO MBER 22, CARO
THE CONTACT BY THE ATTACKING
PLAYER ON THE CAROLINA
NOW, SVECHNIKOV, INTO THE
ANAHEIM ZONE.
JARVIS. DS LEFT IN
JARVIS FINDS DOMI.
DOMI, UP VEN A SHOVE BY SCHUSTE
A SECOND CHANCE.
>> Skip: DOMI IS PLAYING IN
THROUGH CENTER ICE.
CENTERININ
NECAS COMES IN ON GIBSON.
BECAUSE OF THE POST.
NECAS IS CONDS LEFT.
PRODUCTS, THE UNIVERSITY OF NEW
HAMPSHIRE, AND ALMOST A
LACROSSE ATTEMPT FROM
AS SOON AS ZEGRAS COMES
HE BEATS DRYSDALE. .
HE GOT INTO THE LEAGUE. .
HE GETS HIS SECOND